et lorsque la grippe aviaire qu'est-ce
que vous avez inventé alors fred vous
allez ça vous êtes fous de ma gueule
pas du tout je sais ce que vous avez un
rendez vous avez un grand manteau en
matière plastique transparent pour
patrice que les corbeaux de la peste
parce qu'en fait ça se transmet un
sessad anaïs emery le problème c'est que
les masques y en aura pas voilà ça on
sait cinca problèmes de production en
quantité la grippe elle arrivera bon à
90 % de risques ça veut dire quoi 90%
tous les chambres d'épidémiologie
calcule le risque de mutation à 90% de
probabilités voire 100% donc elle arrive
la grippe et bien non d'ici cinq ans on
a le temps de se préparer de fabriquer
la cape de même car même si on avait des
masques il faut des lunettes parce que
ça rentre par les muqueuses des yeux
et puis c'est un aérosol quand on se
parle
à combien ces trois maintenant que ça on
éternuements toux de mettre en paroles
donc c'est un halo sûr que les
bouteilles d'evian coach donc ça se
déposent l'aérosol dans les cheveux
c'est pourquoi ils nous le disent pas ça
à la télévision
alors je le dis ça se déposent partout
donc 60% des rhumes à peu près on les
attrape
on avait un café on fait ça on ramasse
l'aérosol des gouttelettes de pluie
cela s'appelle des postillons mais qu'on
scopique 1 et donc et comme le virus de
la grippe vie 3 4 heures à l'air libre
si on fait ça qu'après un chasseur bien
c'est bien et tranquille dans ce café
la cape font pas moi je détestais à la
maison c'est indispensable
le quoi le z derrière maintenant il
faudra qu'on puisse être autonome ne pas
se mettre dans les mains du gouvernement
qui ne pourra pas alimenter les gens en
quarantaine du corps pas de masse ce qui
va le faire nous apporter à manger
donc pour en fait ce qu'il faut éviter
c'est la dislocation sociale l'épidémie
tome en trois jours on devient des
brutes faut le savoir il faut arriver à
avoir une autonomie pendant une ou deux
heures pour aller faire ses courses un
pas indispensable qu'on se remette pas
comme des bébés en disant que fait
l'état l'état pourra pas faire grand
chose et le tamiflu c'est très compliqué
parce que ça marche dans les 48 heures
de la teinte alors les gars les médecins
comment ils savent en 48 heures où sont
les hypocondriaques les grippes aviaire
et les grippes saisonnières
donc avec une cape en sort ce cap en
plastique transparent mais on polar on
peut l'attaquer on peut faire des trucs
marrants peut se mettre tout nu en
dessous blaguer et la cape m'intéresse
c'est de forcer le virus intrants à à
saint pacte et sur le plastique et de
son jusqu'au sol pour qu'il aille se
condenser avec les gouttelettes et il
est toujours au sol sans doute nous
parce que le virus va frapper un mardi
gras c'est la seule question qu'on se
pose est évidemment ça paraît rigolo
vous serez bien content que je vous lis
vos rêves cup alors je prévois pour les
angoisses et moi je suis resté une heure
de soucis fermeture éclair oui deux
manèges dommages au son de the artist
est autrement
2 comme ça respire normalement on voit
quelqu'un à 5 mètres pour les
hypocondriaques dit m on referme les
fermetures c'est comme les voitures côte
phares côte pas mais ça va durer un mois
de passer un mois c'est rien leur donner
s'ils ont mal à capuche n'aura pas parce
que y'a une place dans les hôpitaux avec
un tatouage de cette fameuse cape
mais n'existe pas c'est un fait que
quelqu'un la maison avec ma soeur
l'intérêt ce que je veux c'est un truc
qu'on puisse fabriquer à la maison parce
que qu'on retombe pas ce point des
masses et être tributaire direction qui
ne pourra pas produire donc ce qui
m'amuse c'est de voir si on peut
effectivement le fabriquer à la maison
le truc dans le dos en fait c'est un fil
de fer très fin pour que le plastique
reste là qu'on doit tout ça c'est pour
aller faire ses courses
ouais c'est pas plus pratique de se
faire livrer je sais pas je pose des
questions qui qui va livrer son secteur
à la cape et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu